sir smoochaloo will bid ado
governor grab that backside we'll step
aside
he loved to harass now he's out on his
ass
he turned albany into malbenny
cuomo's unemployed so let that let's
enjoy the shade and freud
all right i'll stop surely by now you've
heard the news the love gov who couldn't
keep his lips off anything and i mean
anything has resigned effective in 14
days before he made the announcement he
took a trip down memory lane
i thought a hug
and putting my arm around a staff person
while taking a picture was friendly
but she found it to be too forward
i kissed a woman on the cheek at a
wedding and i thought i was being nice
but she felt that it was too aggressive
i said on national tv to a doctor
wearing ppe and giving me a covered nose
nasal swab
you make that gown look good oh wow it's
impressive that he held on this long
looks like all that groping must have
built up his grip strength
he reminded me of a contestant on those
touch the car contests you know the last
person out of 20 or 30 left touching a
brand new car wins it he just assumed he
was going to outlast all the other bozos
it worked so far for his brother
but he was wrong turns out he touched
too many cars if by cars you mean women
the lesson here sexual harassment is bad
in fact these days it's worse than
contributing to the deaths of thousands
of elderly in nursing homes
especially if a few other democrat
governors had the same policy but what a
difference a year makes right says the
media but remember it's not us who put
him on the pedestal we all knew he was a
creep we didn't build him up so he could
tumble that's on cnn the view and late
night crap fest tv shows who created a
myth out of the monster they tried to
make a beast look good like the sports
coat they put on frankenstein's monster
except instead of bigfoot the monster
has happy hands
you see a spectacular political leader
emerging from this in andrew cuomo
governor cuomo who as politicians go is
among the most sophisticated
communicators how would you contrast
cuomo and president trump's handling of
the crisis
truth versus mendacity governor cuomo i
think is is one of the heroes on the
front lines i think that governor cuomo
was just right on um in all of the
efforts that we took early on trevor you
call yourself a homosexual and i i i
agree with you i feel like i'm a
homosexual too
that's gonna live for a long time this
is important because the new narrative
will be the rise and fall of andrew
cuomo as if it's a self-inflicted wound
but it's just not that way it was the
press who created the monster whose
flaws became that much more obvious the
more they blew him up they made him king
while everyone else saw right through it
and now they're trying to change the
story so they aren't culpable
but one person was onto this guy's grift
from day one and she's forecasting
sunnier skies with a chance of i told
you so
joining us with a glass of tequila and
party favors fox news senior
meteorologist janice dean
janice
i i'm not supposed to be drinking
because i'm on meds but i will take a
sip in your honor
well done do you think it would happen
this quickly
you know what i have to say that today i
thought he was gonna blame everyone else
like he did with the nursing homes blame
god and mother nature in the new york
times or the new york post rather
because we all know the new york times
didn't report fairly on it also fox news
and president trump he blamed everyone
except the guy that signed the order for
46 days to put infected patients into
nursing homes governor andrew cuomo so
when he
all of a sudden started saying well i
want to do something for new york new
yorkers or new york tough and i don't
want to have to let everyone go through
an impeachment i resign
i was surprised
i was surprised you remember okay what
was what was the response from his
office there was was it a tweet when
they said what did they say to you that
kind of like insulted you at the start
of this
right
it was uh a column i think in the daily
mail where they got rich as a party
which is one of his you know top
i call him the troll the troll dog uh
who said well she's not a reliable
source on anything except the weather
well i think i forecasted this one
pretty good and it was a long range
forecast
i got one more question for you before
we go i know you're going to be on
hannity and i'm going to be watching
that what would you tell cuomo if you
saw him right now
i don't i don't ever want to see his i
actually would like to see him in
handcuffs before i see him in person how
about that there you go
thank you janice congratulations you're
one tough broad janice
anderson's a hero love you guys see you
later thank you see you soon
all right katie what about this covet i
mean the the coveted nursing home stuff
are they actually going to follow
through with that when they know that
there are other politicians involved do
you think there are some democrats in
the new york state legislature who say
that they want to but i have a feeling
that they will not and i think that the
resignation today was more about
protecting the democratic party than it
was about you know
saying i'm sorry for sexually harassing
11 of these women with the report and
i've let everybody down based on what he
said and the reason i think that is
because the democrats in new york didn't
have to impeach him yeah they get to
walk away from that he gets to go and
move on with this five million dollars
that he got with his book deal and then
president joe biden didn't have to ask
doj to launch any kind of civil rights
investigation and they already got rid
of the civil rights investigation into
the nursing homes and it's easier for
democrats now because democrat governor
in new jersey democrat governor in
michigan other democrats around the
country also signed similar orders and
the democratic party doesn't want this
big investigation of the party as a
whole
on the state level
of the covid investigation and it's more
serious people died so it's not that
this doesn't matter i just i'm cynical
about the intentions here kat uh what
are your thoughts
i was just thinking about how a few
months ago when he had the nipple rings
out yes
and i said he was wearing that he wasn't
even wearing a bra so you could see the
nipple rings during the press conference
and i defended that i said you know i
don't want to kink shame and
i i i actually stand by that so all of
our viewers who have nipple rings i
stand with you um
yes but what i did what i did not know
that was that his nipple ring display
was actually the least offensive thing
about him by far yeah which is rare to
say about someone with nipple rings yeah
exactly
usually you know if you you know your
nipple rings often can be a cry for help
i found especially when you pull on them
tyrus
feel free to piggyback off of my point
yeah you know i can't pee
[Laughter]
your little legs would just it would be
murder
you know i just i think it's funny when
we see main street media they appoint
these heroes cnn's record's getting
pretty bad you got the avenatti hero yes
ooh boy he was robbing handicapped kids
and then you got cuomo who's giving the
iceman a run for money as a serial
killer with
with old folks but
the most important thing for us all to
remember is he did his only his only
crime
is that he loves too much yes
you know what he's actually sad he's
actually the second man with nipple
rings to lie to me
why do you keep well
we're supposed to know i've been drunk
it's just it's just
amazing to me that he
even with the investigation because we
all know you must respect the
investigation yes the investigation is
there he didn't and the investigation
didn't say he did it six times or four
times which is still bad yeah he did
eleven hundred percent i mean a soccer
he scored 100 on an investigation it's
not that's not an a like he failed
miserably he resigned what do you need
two weeks for he's divorced
none of the kids live in the mansion he
literally should be leaving a half hour
you got to plan the going away party oh
no no there's he got something in the
mic he's yeah i wouldn't put it past him
to where he has a change of heart and
the outcry from broken-hearted
supporters everywhere stay in there and
fight
my i thought
he should run for new york mayor yeah
today yes yes joe
what could you be thinking lots going
through my head right now first off
i thought that line about uh the
frankenstein monster wearing the jacket
deserved a little more to be quite
honest
i agreed because if you remember the
frankenstein it was why is he wearing a
sport coat he was the first hipster
with a sports coat the bad haircut yeah
it wasn't a collared shirt yeah it was
how dare you both frankenstein was 6 10.
he didn't have much choice in clothes in
those days it was like jacket or cowhide
that's a good point also i'm a little
leery of when a politician
says that something's going to end in
two weeks yeah
but the other
the other thing that it made me think is
that uh
i think new york probably misses elliot
spitzer yeah at this point all that guy
did was was sleep with prostitutes and
that looks pretty good to me
i mean
[Laughter]
have you considered prostitution no why
aren't you wearing a jacket
anyway up next a member of the squad
danced at a wedding forgetting the virus
she might be spreading
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else